don't see why it's impossible to enforce
the law we enforce the law on lots of
other things it's extremely difficult to
get to a country like America or Britain
legally
why is it so wildly easy to get into it
illegally I'm sorry it is easy ever
talks about the perilous Journey you
only have to spend a few hours in a boat
it only costs a few thousand dollars
it's very easy you walk straight in and
you've got a hotel and then you'll get a
work permit as well the legal route is
extremely difficult the illegal one has
become easy I'm sorry politicians can
sort that out I don't think it's I don't
think it's the world's hardest Rubik's
Cube